c'est un sentiment d'inquiétude qui
domine ici à chisinau capitale moldave
capital d'un petit pays coincé entre la
roumanie et l'ukraine est tiraillé entre
deux grandes zones d'influencé l'europe
et la russie et qui tout simplement a
peur d'être le prochain pays sur la
liste après l'ukraine il ya ce fort
sentiment de vulnérabilité car que
ferait une armée de 6000 soldats
moldaves face au rouleau compresseur
russe un pays qui fait qu'il ne fait ni
partie de l'union européenne ni de
l'otan et c'est clairement la panique
qui a dominé ici aux premiers jours de
la guerre on a pu entendre le bruit des
bombes ici à chisinau nous sommes à 60
kilomètres de la frontière ils sont
nombreux à s'être rués dans les
administrations pour refaire leur
passeport et tous disent eh bien avoir
fait leurs valises se tenir prêt au cas
où avoir déjà un pied dehors car il ya
un autre point noir c'est que la
moldavie son territoire est amputé d'une
région séparatiste autoproclamé défendue
par la russie elle s'appelle la
transnistrie 1500 soldats russes ils
sont positionnés d'importants stocks
d'armes et la crainte c'est que cette
région qui ne veut pas entendre parler
l'union européenne qui veut être
rattachés d'être dans la sphère russe la
crainte c'est que si les grandes villes
ukrainiennes portuaire tels que à mickey
nikolaïev ou odessa tombée aux mains des
russes et bien ils pourraient faire la
jonction avec ses soldats russes
positionné en transnistrie et cela de
fête implanterait le conflit en moldavie
comme ce fut le cas dans le donbass